[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le couvre-feu efficace pour faire face à
la pandémie ni déclaration du directeur
général de la santé dans les colonnes du
journal du dimanche jérôme salomon qui
n'exclut pas des mesures plus strictes
pour l'instant le gouvernement mise sur
déconfinement localisé à toulouse les
quais de la garonne sont fermées
aujourd'hui il en sera de même la
semaine prochaine plus de 2 5 millions
de morts liés au corps et 19 dans le
monde les etats unis sont le pays le
plus touché où washington a donné son
feu vert en troisième vaccin johnson &
johnson en russie où l'épidémie semble
reculer nous irons à moscou où vous le
verrez tout est ouvert
y compris les restaurants et puis
l'arménie face à une grave crise
politique le premier ministre est
fragilisée nikol pashinian qu'il est
sous le feu des critiques l'opposition
lui reproche d'avoir accepté l'accord de
paix dans le haut-karabagh elle appelle
à manifester dans la rue et demande
des missions nous ferons un point sur la
situation sur place avec notre envoyé
spécial à erevan
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
le directeur général de la santé là sur
le couvre-feu fonctionne très bien dans
les colonnes du jdd
jérôme salomon estime que cette mesure
est une bonne solution pour éviter les
rassemblements privé vecteur de
propagation du colis de 19 selon le
directeur général de la santé nos
voisins européens nous envieraient même
le couvre feu
malgré tous nos efforts la situation est
évidemment très tendu
le gouvernement a pris des mesures de
freinage forte en particulier avec le
couvre-feu ce dernier fonctionne très
bien
cette mesure répond bien à la
problématique des rassemblements privé
et intéresse d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos
voisins qui ont été surpris de ses
effets la moselle sera classée zone à
haut risque par l'allemagne dès mardi il
n'y aura pas de quasi fermeture comme à
la frontière avec la république tchèque
et le tyrol autrichien
mais les passages à la frontière
allemande depuis la france seront
restreints il faudra donc à partir de
mardi présenté un test pcr ou
antigénique négatif de -2 48 heures jean
rottner président de la région grand-est
espère trouver un point d'entente sur
les tests pour les travailleurs
frontaliers
[Applaudissements]
depuis quelques jours nous avions plutôt
l'impression d'une collaboration
fructueuse avec les autorités allemandes
nous demandons de pouvoir utiliser des
tests antigénique les tests antigénique
sont plus simples plus souple et je
crois serait mieux acceptée je milite
également pour l'utilisation de tests
salivaires qui ne sont malheureusement
pas validé à l'heure qu'il est par nos
amis allemands
mais les tests salivaires serait d'une
efficacité et d'une souplesse
d'utilisation beaucoup plus rapide
nous ne souhaitons pas être dans la même
situation que la tchéquie ou le tyrol
autrichien où les frontières ont été
fermées de manière physique
à quand la réouverture des bars et des
restaurants dans une tribune signée dans
le jdd 40 parlementaires de tous bords
politiques se mobilisent ils demandent à
l'exécutif de rouvrir ces établissements
pour les
et je n'ai dès le 30 mars avec bien sûr
des mesures sanitaires adéquates
l'un des signataires le député modem du
loiry richard ramos s'alarme sur le
risque de pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans
ce secteur à l'arrêt depuis quatre mois
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
la quasi-totalité des professionnels du
secteur ont toujours respecté les
consignes sanitaires et mis en place des
procédures strictes dans leurs
établissements au delà des conditions
financières dramatiques des
professionnels et de l'augmentation
probable des dépôts de bilan il faut
également prendre en compte la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre du secteur la crise
sanitaire et la fermeture des
restaurants accentue le phénomène car
ceux qui travaillent dans ces
établissements sont à présent en intérim
dans d'autres secteurs
beaucoup d'entre eux ne souhaitent pas
retourner travailler dans la
restauration
il faut donc rapidement rouvrir ces
lieux mêmes de façon partielle pour ne
pas perdre ce qui aurait encore l' envie
de travailler dans les restaurants nous
en appelons au premier ministre afin que
ces établissements rouvre à partir du 30
mars
ceci avec les procédures sanitaires
adéquates et alors que le monde de la
culture est lui aussi à l'arrêt depuis
plusieurs semaines le collectif respire
se retrouvent chaque samedi pour une
chorale improvisée à figeac dans le
département du lot en occitanie sur la
place du marché
les chanteurs veulent donner de la joie
aux habitants
malgré la pandémie ils doivent s'adapter
drouot mesures sanitaires que les
autorités veulent faire respecter sur
place le reportage d'hervé grand champ
et de maxime à bolland
les gens
pour
chanter pour lutter contre la morosité
voilà l'objectif du collectif respire à
figeac
ce petit groupe de chanteurs amateurs
donne rendez vous aux habitants de la
commune du lot chaque samedi sur la
place du marché
il tente de redonner le sourire aux
passants face au contexte sanitaire et
sociale difficile
le but du collectif c'était de fédérer
les gens et puis voilà on s'est
retrouvés parce qu'on se disait qu'on
était tous inquiets de ce qui était en
train de se passer et on voulait essayer
de voir ce qu'on pouvait faire un autre
petit niveau de citoyens pour amener un
petit peu de joie aux gens parce que
c'était d'une morosité incroyable il ya
trois mois
et là ça commence à bouger un petit peu
les gens commencent à avoir de nouveau
le sourire à redon à danser à chanter
le but c'était juste sans tête c'était
donner de la joie aux gens mais
l'événement festif a pris une autre
tournure samedi 20 février
la petite vingtaine de participants a
été prise à part par la police
municipale et la gendarmerie
le motif non respect du port du masque
dans une zone obligatoire et
rassemblement non autorisé sur la place
publique une intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui n'a pas manqué de faire
réagir les passants c'est à la fois moi
je le porte le masque un jeu va papa
c'est malheureux mais je dire si on peut
veut pas payer une amende on est obligé
de le mettre mais ça n'empêche pas que
chanter ça empêche pas de faire plein de
choses je peux pas dire que je suis
d'accord avec ce qu'on va dire cette
décision un peu dictatorial d'aller
m une prune à quelqu'un qui essaye de
mettre un peu de joie de vivre
si deux amendes ont été distribuées
selon le maire de la commune cela n'a
pas freiné les membres du collectif
respire au contraire ils étaient encore
plus nombreux ce samedi à chanter sur la
place du marché
la convention citoyenne sur le climat
s'est achevée aujourd'hui les citoyens
tirés au sort ont planché sur des
mesures transmises au gouvernement au
mois de juin dernier à un programme vert
avec en tout 150 propositions mais le
groupe n'a pas le juger que le
gouvernement les avait bien pris en
compte
cyrielle benavides bull en dénote que
l'on donne en général aux mauvais élèves
cent dix neuf membres de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat ont dû évaluer
lors de la dernière session
la prise en compte du gouvernement face
à la centaine de mesures proposées en
juin dernier le vent et les citoyens
n'ayant pas eu l'impression d'être
écoutés les moyennes attribuées à
l'issue de l'expérience sont donc plutôt
basse 3,4 sur dix pour le logement 3,7
sur 10 pour la production et le travail
l'alimentation et les transports 4 sur
10 pour la consommation 4,1 sur 10 pour
la constitution une moyenne générale peu
glorieuse de 3,76 sur 10 cette
initiative écologique avait été pensé
par emmanuel macron pour répondre à la
crise des gilet jaune
né d'une taxe carbone sur les carburants
les propositions son objectif réduire
d'au moins 40% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 dans le
respect de la justice sociale un but
inatteignable selon le panel de français
à qui l'on a posé la question
la majorité des citoyens présents a jugé
cette baisse de 40% bon peu probable
avec une note moyenne de 2 et demi sur
10 un projet néanmoins faisable pour la
ministre de la transition écologique
même s'il reste encore du travail
l'étude du haut conseil pour le climat
dit que le texte est utile et part dans
la bonne direction
les études que nous avons disque
globalement tous
les tous les enjeux tous les terrains
sur lesquels on doit avancer son couvert
après ils nous disent que sur un certain
nombre d'aspects on n'est pas allé au
bout et il faudrait peut-être revoir un
certain nombre de déchéance ou un
certain nombre d'objectifs à condition
que cet objectif sur plusieurs années ne
soient pas revu à la baisse car trop
ambitieux à l'instar des chiffres
annuels français au début du mois de
février le président s'était félicité
d'une baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 1,7 pour cent pour
2019 un objectif soit disant atteint
mais qui était initialement fixée à 2,5
pour cent je vous le disais en titre 2,5
millions de morts liées aux kovy 19 ont
été comptabilisés dans le monde selon un
décompte de la fp beaucoup de pays ont
entamé leur campagne de vaccination en
russie la situation sanitaire s'améliore
et pour cause on y vaccine massivement
avec spoutnik v moscou a levé ces
mesures sanitaires retour à une vie
presque normale c'est ce que nous
explique depuis moscou
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
moscou continue à vivre sa vie post
confinement théâtres et musées bars et
restaurants salles de sport et salons de
beauté tout est au vert
le maire de moscou sergueï sobianine
envisage même à la levée des dernières
restrictions sanitaires non à dieu
j'espère que nous avons surmonté le pire
même si quelque chose arrive de nouveau
nous avons évolué nous savons que m'ont
traitée comment lutter contre cette
maladie est ce qu'il faut faire
dieu nous en garde en cas de nouvelles
situations à caractère épidémiologique
ou d'autres défis nous auront évolué et
nous serons prêts à y faire face
beaucoup mieux qu'il ya un an c'est
également un grand avantage je
n'approuve pas vraiment la levée des
restrictions
parce que
- comme ça je veux porter ce bandana
style et au lieu d'un masque
je suis très content de l'ambiance qui
s'installe à moscou beaucoup de
personnes ne prêtent aucune attention
aux copies beaucoup sont fatigués de
devoir porter les masques et d'observer
la distanciation sociale sauf que dans
le métro personne ne la respectent à mes
yeux c'est une bonne chose à faire
le moment est venu l'essentiel est
d'éviter la troisième vague
si tout va bien après la levée des
restrictions alors qu'ils élèvent les
gens sont fatigués du mode de vie que
nous vivons actuellement
j'ai l'impression de vivre comme dans
des cages on veut la liberté sait très
bien qu'en russie bien que nos
frontières soient fermés nous tenions
nous continuons à travailler commencions
à aller aux concerts en un mot la vie
continue et nous revenons à la vie pas
de nouveau confinement en vue pas de
pénurie de vaccins la russie en
enregistré 3 moscou aurait été un
paradis sur terre au milieu de l'europe
confiné au mit le froid les cours agents
et les premiers volontaires ont reçu
leur dose du vaccin spoutnik light une
nouvelle version de spoutnik v qui
s'administre en une seule dose de vaccin
sera utilisé chez les jeunes de 18 à 30
ans il développe une bonne réponse
immunitaire et produisent suffisamment
d'anticorps dès la première injection
une solution qui pourrait être très
efficace dans les pays où il ya beaucoup
de contamination sur spoutnik light
écoutez michael shooter il est médecin
chef d'une clinique à moscou ont inspiré
reading les bénévoles peuvent se faire
vacciner au cours de la phase iii des
recherches sur le vaccin spoutnik light
il constitue une nouvelle version du
vaccin déjà connu de spoutnik v celle ci
se distingue de la version précédente
par le fait que scout nick lane ne
contient qu'un seul composant
il a été produit avec les mêmes
technologies que scouting v mais la
nouvelle version peut administrer en une
seule injection au lieu de deux une
seule injection
c'est beaucoup plus pratique elle permet
de vacciner beaucoup plus rapidement et
massivement et de former le nombre
d'immuniser nécessaires pour vaincre le
virus est alors que la russie a assoupli
ses règles la pologne elle durcit ces
restrictions en raison d'une flambée de
kovy de 19 dans certaines régions il ya
quelques semaines pourtant varsovie
avait allégé ces mesures sanitaires
ouvrant notamment cinéma et stations de
ski isabelle carré secousse quelques
rayons de soleil sur le visage malgré un
port du masque fraîchement imposées par
les autorités polonaises depuis ce
samedi
jusqu'ici le port d'écran faciaux de
protection ou de foulard suffisait mais
en raison d'une résurgence de l'épidémie
depuis la mi février le ministre
polonais de la santé a annoncé de
nouvelles restrictions ce mercredi nous
nous orientons vers une limitation des
entrées à la frontière nous allons aussi
devoir régionaliser les restrictions une
régionalisation des restrictions
notamment pour la région vernis mazurie
dans le nord-est du pays où la situation
est la plus alarmante avec des taux
d'infection qui représente plus du
double de la moyenne nationale dans
cette partie du pays
installations sportives lieux culturels
hôtels et nombreuses écoles resteront
fermées dans le reste du pays les bars
restaurants hôtels discothèques et club
de gym ainsi que la plupart des écoles
resteront fermées
al'inverse des stations de ski des
cinémas des hôtels et des théâtres qui
ont rouvert depuis quelques semaines le
gouvernement affirme cependant que ces
libertés pourront être révoqués
si le nombre de cas augmente de nouveau
pour les polonais ces temps de
restriction sont comme beaucoup une
nouvelle réalité à laquelle il faut
s'adapter
j'essaie de sortir le plus possible sur
tout le week-end de me déplacer en
voiture et pas en transport en commun et
je porte toujours un masque je
désinfecte mes mains et j'évite les
foules
le coc vide restera avec nous pour
toujours
je pense que les vaccins vont devenir
habituelles et qu'ils devront être
réajusté chaque année en raison de
l'apparition de nouveaux variants nous
devrons donc nous habituer à cette
nouvelle réalité
ce week end des restrictions aux
frontières ont aussi été mises en place
pour les voyageurs venant de république
tchèque et de slovaquie qui devront
présenter un test négatif au risque
d'être placée en quarantaine à leur
arrivée en pologne le nombreux
quotidiens de nouveaux cas s'établit
actuellement à plus de 12000 pour une
population de moins de 38 millions
d'habitants
plus de 48 mille personnes ayant perdu
la vie depuis le début de l'épidémie
face aux restrictions sanitaires les
manifestations ne faiblissent pas à
travers le monde au danemark en irlande
ou encore en argentine des milliers de
personnes ont protesté ces dernières 24
heures notamment à buenos aires où les
vaccinations vip provoque la colère
d'une partie de la population un
scandale qui a coûté son poste au
ministre argentin de la santé tour
d'horizon de ces manifestations en
images et sans commentaire
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le vaccin anti kobe 19 johnson & johnson
devrait être approuvé par l'agencé
européenne du médicament
début mars les etats-unis eux ont donné
leur feu vert pour ce vaccin
hier c'est leur troisième ce vaccin
unidose peut être stocké facilement dans
un réfrigérateur au moins trois millions
de do sont prêtes à être distribuées dès
la semaine prochaine selon le
gouvernement américain
une nouvelle formidable pour tous les
américains selon le président joe biden
qui appelle toutefois à ne pas baisser
la garde
johnson & johnson s'est engagé à
acheminer 100 millions de doses aux
états unis avant la fin du mois de juin
le plan de relance de joe biden a été
adopté par la chambre des représentants
à majorité démocrate le texte doit
maintenant être transmis au sénat
principal point d'achoppement la hausse
du revenu minimum les explications de
thé aux combes premier vote et premier
obstacle franchi pour les démocrates et
joe biden par 219 voix contre 212 le
plan de relance de près de 1900
milliards de dollars concocté par la
maison blanche a été validé par la
chambre des représentants
si de voix dissonantes n'ont pas mis à
mal la majorité démocrate
l'histoire pourrait être différente au
sénat la semaine prochaine
en cause une promesse électorale de joe
biden
la hausse du salaire minimum qui
passerait de 7,25 1 15 $ de l'heure en
en pratique je ne m'implique pas dans
les règles du sénat américain
mais en matière de valeurs je peux
simplement dire que nous n'aurons pas de
repos tant que nous n'aurons pas passer
le salaire minimum à 15 dollars nous
sommes engagés dans la lutte pour les 15
dollars depuis longtemps source des
tourments démocrate une personnalité
méconnue de la politique américaine
elizabeth mac de 9
cette dernière est la gardienne des
procédures complexes du sénat une
fonction de crucial à la chambre haute
du congrès jeudi elle a jugé impossible
d'inclure cette mesure dans le projet de
loi
un avis accepté par joe biden d'autant
plus que certains sénateurs démocrates
modérés ont exprimé des réserves quant à
cette mesure
al'inverse l'ale la plus progressiste du
parti appelle à outrepasser cet avis
établi par une fonctionnaires non élus
de leur côté les républicains
considèrent cette hausse du revenu
minimum comme inefficace est-ce que cela
a un rapport avec la crise du coc vide
combien de petites entreprises ont déjà
fermé à cause de cette mesure
toutes les études montrent que cette
mesure fait perdre encore plus d'emplois
regardez ce qu'il s'est passé à seattle
quand ils ont mis ce minimum en place
cela a coûté leur emploi aux personnes
qui en ont le plus besoin donc pour moi
c'est juste plus de politique et c'est
mal parce que vous savez au sénat ce
texte ne va pas sur vire une polémique
qui fait craindre à joe biden un
allongement des débats au congrès le
président américain a exhorté samedi le
sénat à une adoption rapide du plan de
relance alors que le versement des
allocations chômage doit cesser le 14
mars prochain
de son côté la hausse du salaire minimum
pourrait se trouver un nouvel adversaire
de taille en la personne de donald trump
ce week end
l'ex président fait son grand retour sur
le devant de la scène politique et
pourrait s'exprimer sur le sujet
aujourd'hui à l'occasion du
rassemblement annuel qui réunit toutes
les tendances conservatrices du pays
[Musique]
en arménie le premier ministre nikol
pashinian est fragilisée depuis qu'il a
accepté de signer l'accord de paix dans
le haut-karabagh sous l'égide de la
russie sa décision de limoger le chef
d'état major a été refusée par le
président à erevan partisans pro et anti
pashinian se mobilisent le point sur
place avec notre envoyé spécial david
kelly fin un nouveau rassemblement anti
à nikol pashinian qui s'est achevée vers
18h30 heure locale
ici devant le parlement une mobilisation
qui a été plutôt festive 1 puisque une
scène a été montée
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
où plusieurs prises de parole en public
se sont succédé des concerts également
de personnalités publiques venu soutenir
ce mouvement anti à nikol pashinian en
tout cas vous le voyez aussi à certaines
attentes ont été construites ici un
devant le parlement des tentes qui
abrite certains manifestants qui sont là
depuis jeudi qui dorment dans ces tentes
afin de maintenir à cette contestation
populaire et des tentes rouges également
que vous pouvez apercevoir où des mets
culinaires issus du haut karabagh sont
donnés gratuitement aux manifestants
chaque jour afin de contester un contre
le pouvoir de nikol pashinian jugé
responsable de la défaite militaire dans
cette région une défaite militaire est
vécu comme une humiliation nationale par
certains manifestants
je vous propose d'en écouter quelques
uns à ce sujet
nous venons ici chaque jour avec un seul
objectif nous devons nous débarrasser du
traître nikol pashinian au plus tôt
c'est notre but
il a vendu notre pays ici se rassemblent
des gens qui ont mal pour leur patrie
qui sont prêts jour et nuit
malgré la neige et le froid à exprimer
leur désaccord avec ce qu'il s'est passé
et se passe encore dans notre pays nous
sommes proches de la victoire
nous en sommes sûrs aujourd'hui ou
demain il ne sera plus au pouvoir
[Musique]
je m'attends à ce qu'il y ait plus de
manifestations qu'auparavant car les
gens ont commencé à comprendre qu'il y a
eu une trahison global commises par
l'homme qui occupe maintenant le poste
de premier ministre est notre seule
exigence et qu'il quitte ce poste
chaud nikol pashinian qui arrêtait sa
demande de révocation du chef d'état
major de l'armée il a également appelé à
tous ses partisans à se réunir demain à
18h30 place de la république non loin
adieu parlement pour pouvoir poursuivre
le combat pour l'arménie est mais il a
également appelé au calme pour éviter
tout affrontement à civile demain entre
les deux camps écouter michel croc comme
certains représentants des forces
politiques seront invités à participer à
la manifestation
nous leur proposerons également de
prendre la parole lors de la
manifestation pour que celle de demain
servent dans le fond les deux objectifs
que j'ai mentionné instinct me rappelle
mon cas ouvert à tous le premier
objectif
je le répète est de montrer qu'en
république d'arménie
il y à une société forte une société qui
peut former et protéger son pouvoir
je parle bien de la société pas du
gouvernement
[Musique]
le second objectif est de montrer qu'en
arménie la page des affrontements civile
du 1er mars est tournée je veux dire
qu'il est exclu que ce genre de
situation se reproduise
et nous pouvons tous ensemble être
garant de ce processus avant tout le
gouvernement bien sûr mais aussi la
société il acheta vole cette
mobilisation a qui s'est achevée à vers
18h30 je vous le disais elle s'est
déroulée dans le calme et a globalement
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que malgré
quelques tensions quelques débordements
et des images violentes globalement les
forces de l'ordre contrôlant ce
soulèvement populaire un important
dispositif de sécurité a été mis en
place tout autour du parlement ce qui
devrait être le cas demain également
place de la république est ici juste
devant le parlement arménien le chef de
la diplomatie européenne joseph bourrel
a condamné aujourd'hui la répression
meurtrière menée par les militaires en
birmanie il a également confirmé
l'adoption de sanctions la birmanie où
la violence contre les manifestants
opposés à la junte a franchi un cap
ces personnes ont été tuées ce matin et
les blessés continuent d'affluer à
l'hôpital de dahouët les contestataires
demandent la libération d'un accent
succi renversé il ya un mois lors d'un
coup d'état la répression des forces de
l'ordre d'abord commencé avec des gaz
lacrymogènes des canons à eau puis des
balles en caoutchouc et des balles
réelles
il s'agit là de
la répression la plus meurtrière depuis
le 1er février dernier
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est là mon les
actes et je dépense trop d'état je pense
en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que